here with more fox news contributor joe
concha now there were three settlements
uh as relates nbc
uh the washington post and cnn in the
cnn case you had a similar setup it was
thrown out originally on summary
judgment but on appeal
uh he got a lot of money from fake news
cnn it's
non-disclosed but i'm sure it was a
significant sum of money this kid did
nothing wrong even when the videotape
came out showing that he did not
approach mr phillips
they still claimed he did and they still
called him racist and he's not a public
figure so you don't have the times v
sullivan standard joe
i think he wins again
oh absolutely if it goes to appeal and
look you called anna navarro a
far left
analyst remember sean she's called a
republican strategist when she's
introduced on the view or on cnn
strategist for whom exactly i'd love to
hear how many winning campaigns that
she's done but but you're right given
the president here what we saw with the
washington post and cnn settling out of
court for remember those are 250 million
dollar lawsuits against those
organizations it's interesting that this
judge who was appointed by jimmy carter
by the way clearly on the back nine at
this point decides to throw these suits
out
and you think about the way the new york
times or rolling stone or these other
outlets reported on sandman painting him
as the basically the face of teenage
racism you know it was no different than
the way cnn or the washington post did
and it's hard not to see this ruling as
anything other than politically
motivated because cnn or the washington
post you know they have plenty of legal
resources and they knew that it was in
their best interest to settle because
they're on the losing side of this
argument based on what you mentioned
before the video evidence that anybody
could see at home in the court of a
public opinion say you know you got this
wrong so you know the the judge says
there's no there there uh where's the
beef trust me there's plenty of beef
here and you're right sandman continues
this this pursuit he will win he will
win just like if the first time with cnn
thrown out same thing summary judgment i
would anticipate on appeal uh as long as
he doesn't get another jimmy carter
judge i think he'll be okay all right
joe concha we always appreciate your
insight thank you for being with us hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else